what's going on guys
marvels ant-man is in theaters right now
in fact to climb the ant hill to the top
of the box office we had the awesome
opportunity to sit down with one of the
film stars Michael Pena and the film's
director Peyton Reed we asked them some
of your burning questions and we got a
little inside info about the MCU warning
if you haven't seen the film there's
some ant-man spoilers ahead so see the
movie and come back and watch it if you
haven't that's how that works we are
here with Michael Pena one of the stars
of ant-man he plays Luis Michael thank
you so much for being here my pleasure
but first congratulations on an awesome
flick thank you it was way funnier than
I expected how much was scripted and how
much was kind of improv my stuff was
mainly improved so I'm literally
imitating a buddy he's the kind of guy
where I'm like a Pablo what'd you do
this week and he's like I went to jail
thought nobody thinks like that guy yeah
I mean so they would write some stuff
that was really a I thought was really
awesome and then you know his voice
would like you know just give me
different options I was so nervous I
swear because I'm like my kid I read him
like a bunch of Marvel stuff does he
have a favorite one Thor no but he told
me actually like right before I left
he's like don't mess it up that day
thanks buddy joining us is the director
of ant-man Peyton Reed Peyton thank you
so much for being here thank you for
having me
what was the pressure like coming into
this movie when the process had already
been started coming in well it was fast
I came on the movie about the same time
Adam McKay and Paul had signed on to
rewrite and rework the script so McKay
the thing you may not know about him is
he is an obsessive Marvel Comics nerd as
well okay so there were at least four
major conceptual things in the movie
that had not existed in previous drafts
that we were like we're doing an ant-man
movie we got to have this stuff in there
so we we figured out a way to sort of
put it in there but make it organic to
the story we were telling I would love
for them to like you know pull like you
know an Iron Man with like Don Cheadle
who was the friend the sidekick like the
first Latino Avenger the same way Rhodey
got his like own thing you should tell
Kevin Feige that oh I will absolutely
what's his home number
correct me an IMDB if we're wrong but
you directed the pre-show for Honey I
Shrunk the Kids the ride that's
absolutely right
Irie its destiny yes ya know I met ya
kismet kismet but it yeah it's kind of
an odd thing but it is true and was
there any talk of uh bringing in Rick
Moranis to play hank pym there was talk
well not to play hank pym but it was one
of the things i I of course obsessively
went back and watched all the shrinking
movies I could think of and when it got
to Honey I Shrunk the kids it's like I
really miss Rick Moranis man and there
was talk about like should we have him
do some strategic cameo in the movie but
we already had a couple of strategic
cameos in the movie and then it felt
like okay that might be gilding the lily
and it also was like if we're gonna get
Rick Moranis back yeah he's gotta have
more than a cameo right what would the
first Latino Avengers name be and mang
ant mang I really maybe not even the T
and Matt will happen man I'm tired
Marvel had less of a presence at this
year's comic-con DC major presence do
you want to a throwdown you want to take
any Barb's at DC right now I love DC I
also grew up reading you know some
Batman stuff I said a Kamandi the last
boy on earth DC making a Kamandi movie
anyone should that's what you're doing
hey DC people make us Kamandi the last
boy on earth movie so I know there are a
lot of Secrets about everything coming
out in the Marvel Universe all the
movies how annoying is it to keep
everything on lockdown under rap it's
not annoying it's just fear I was doing
a movie in England I got that you know I
got the script I was it great man thank
you very much he's like no I'll be out
here but now I get it
we can if you know any little spoiler
you know the fans are really
knowledgeable so you if you say even the
littlest thing they already know like a
third of the like the last act you can't
have that we're gonna put you on the
spot and ask you some spoilers and let's
get spoiling yeah let's do it so Falcon
shows up in an amazing surprise scene
III think I have to credit Adam McKay
with that that was when McKay came in
and was like you know one of the great
joys as a kid reading Marvel was sort of
the cross-pollination and like oh I love
this hero with these powers and I love
this hero with these powers what
happens if I think we didn't if we did
something like Captain America of Thor
it might have sort of taken the movie
into this whole left turn and become
about that but but you know the
character of Sam just felt like the
right character and there's also a shout
out to the Avengers when they say why
don't we just call the Avengers what
were some other ways that were talked
about as far as infusing their existence
well to me it was really organic and
mostly to the character of Hank Pym I
wanted to give him some definite
opinions he's an outsider
he's got definite attitudes about Howard
Stark Tony Stark the Avengers he does
not trust any of them is that a
precursor to what's gonna happen in
civil war I think it's safe to say that
Tim's
attitude about the Avengers and the
Starks affects Scott Lang will you tell
us right now that ant-man will
definitely have Captain America's back
in civil war I'm not gonna answer that
one okay all right you could get the
Russos in here uh-huh well then put them
on the hot seat love to Russo's if you
show up the coffee's great yeah it's
really good is there any rivalry between
directors do you guys haze each other
when a new Marvel director comes into
the know it's actually the opposite
which is another thing I love and we
just set scott derrickson off to to
London to do Doctor Strange which I
cannot wait oh yeah I love Doctor
Strange um
so speaking of Doctor Strange when
ant-man goes into that infinitesimally
smaller zone and keeps shrinking and
shrinking there were elements of the
Doctor Strange universe in that sequence
how much did that affect you and were
there any was there any talk of bringing
Doctor Strange and right there
that was another thing the first time
McKay and I talked about amen we both
wanted to embrace that psychedelic era
of Marvel that sort of late 60s early
70s psychedelic version you know and
Doctor Strange is certainly gonna do it
getting into whatever they're getting
into parallel universes and ultimate
realities and that stuff so we really
wanted to you know this is the the end
of Phase two and to give a little tease
of what might be in store for Phase
three yeah but again organic to our
story because it's this moment of
self-sacrifice for Scott and I have to
say if you have a very keen eye there
there might be you might be able to
detect a clue about something in the
quantum realm when you watch the movie
now some people who said they might have
seen a silhouette
they might have they might have yes
confirm or deny well there is definitely
something there to obtain in the quantum
realm yeah tell us exactly what it is
and where it fits in well listen I think
we clearly setup hain't Pimm's character
as a guy who is motivated in large part
by this loss in his life he lost his his
wife yeah according to his side she
can't go into the quantum realm and get
out but Scott Lang does it yeah so at
the end of the movie you know we see Pym
leaning in it's like you sure you see
anything in there anything at all in
scouts like I'm sorry I don't remember
but you can see that something's taken
hold with him and it might have
reignited this obsession it remains to
be seen if that's a good thing or a bad
thing and that's that was a good Michael
Douglas impression there Scott did you
see anything in the header there love
that now the Internet we've asked our
Twitter followers for questions to ask
Peyton Reed I'm gonna some excellent yes
what's wasps future and will we see the
wasp before ant-man - obviously she's
she's gonna step into a much more
important role in terms of whether we'll
see her before ant-man - that's a giant
question mark who knows I actually don't
know the answer to that you never show
the original wasps face was that by
design yeah it really was about like
well you know if we were to see Janet
Van Dyne at some point in a Marvel
Universe is she the same age is she
older well I mean they're all these
questions how does how are things
affected didn't quantum realm in time
and space we don't know okay I'm gonna
put you on the spot big time here okay
we know he's working with Hydra is
Martin Donovan the Mandarin wow he is
Martin Donovan the Mandarin well first
of all I love Martin also to bring him
into the MCU from me with was a victory
there are definitely a lot of paths that
that character could take he's actually
a character in the comics mm-hmm
Mitchell Carson okay so yeah check out
Wikipedia see you know it might give you
some clues as to what might happen with
Carson another one of our Twitter
followers asks any possibility of seeing
giant man in the future listen I think
you know with Hank Pym and Scott Lang
and that technology I think it's safe to
say at some point somewhere you're gonna
see some some real
both for character I hedge my bet cuz it
could be just sort of emotion being
emotional growth or it could be like
giant growth yeah
literal literal Josh yeah there's a good
chance of that things event that Peyton
any possibility of seeing hank pym suit
up as the ant-man in the future
technically it could be done and it
could be done with Michael Douglas I
mean you know listen that whole era in
the comics where ant-man and wasp were
you know this amazing fighting and and
romantic duo well I grew up with that I
loved it so um there there are a lot of
possibilities but I think it'd be
amazing to do sort of a period ant-man
wasp movie would be amazing there are no
plans for it currently but it could be
kick-ass that sounds great please make
it okay cool
okay awesome well I did a nice time
talking to those guys thanks again to
Michael Pena and Peyton Reed for coming
and chatting with us so what was your
favorite part of ant-man let us know in
the comments section below what scene
blew your mind the best answer we're
gonna send you a screen junkies t-shirt
I want to thank you for watching I'm
Howard dick hit me up on Twitter by one
man who could never sneeze with his
helmet on Cobra Commander is in charge
at Comic Con this summer the minions are
back and they forgot the rest of their
pans minions now in theaters